Minneapolis on fire this is getting
serious oh you watch the TV news oh my
goodness all protests are riots and
lighting fires have been started and
just got out of control and we're not
gonna pay attention to the hotels in a
city that has been wracked by this
violence marching peacefully enchanting
games which is going to get more
attention a group of 35 people standing
chanting names singing songs doing the
cupid shuffle as I saw one group of
protesters doing or five people on the
ground bleeding and screaming and crying
and throwing rocks our press is driven
by eyeballs and attention and cliques
and advertising and passion and raising
the anxiety of viewers dramatic images
are money they keep eyeballs on the
screen so they will constantly show
action you need to understand the
limitations of those visuals I'm a
college professor like my doctorate in
political science I teach in a
journalism department I would say across
the board
the coverage has not been very good it's
passing but it's not very good and the
reason it's not very good is because
there are not enough conversations about
the roots of these protests what they
are showing you is what is happening
right now on the ground what those
visuals cannot tell you is the entire
historical context that has led to that
scene on the ground and one thing that a
lot of mainstream media doesn't do well
is give you that full context
[Music]
you can't untangle this moment from
where we are just in this year starting
with February with the coronavirus the
mod Arbor ease lynching having people in
shelter in place having people become
angry that they are in shelter in place
orders having the economy you know
significantly slowed down there are so
many events just since January that led
up to this moment not to mention the
hundreds of years before that this
becomes a very complicated story who is
to blame for the violence
it is crazy that when we talk about
destruction of property that the
presumption is that the unarmed people
who are protesting are more likely to
cause property destruction than the
paramilitary cops who are showing up
because tear gas canisters are really
hot flash bombs can start fires tear gas
leads people to run and break through
windows in order to hide and get help
I'm not saying the police are intending
to cause damage but if you're randomly
shooting out tear gas it's gonna end up
in the back alley with a pile of
newspapers and some garbage does that
mean that there aren't protesters who
engage in destruction of course there
are you know to say that that all this
is turning to looters is like saying
everybody at the party is a drunk driver
no some people will leave and cause
problems but you can't say everybody at
the party is the worst behaving person I
think one thing that we actually don't
do well and don't quite understand is
anti blackness and how it works in our
society how it how it is in our language
and how it is used by mainstream media
we have spent the last month watching
protests who want the country to open up
and we saw images of these people
screaming and yelling and spitting on
police officers who were plainclothes
officers they weren't in riot gear they
weren't in masks
now we see protests based on violence
and death and we see the peaceful
protesters come out but suddenly the
cops come out and riot gear and
everything looks like you know some sort
of violent takeover in some 80s a
post-apocalyptic film what I'm reminded
of our photos in New Orleans of white
people leaving stores with food and the
headline being this is how people are
surviving and black folks leaving the
store with food
and calling them looters
this is about a community that is
treated differently by the police in our
country just consuming the news right
now in the next five days is not going
to give you a good understanding as to
why this is happening
it's the emails I get where people say
well I was in favor of the protesters
and then they turn violent and it's a
problem why are you more offended by
people being violent in response to
state-sponsored violence then you are by
the initial act that cause everything
[Music]
you
[Music]